>> THEY’VE GONE FROM POSITIVITY
4 TO 5 AND NOW IN EXCESS OF 15%.
THAT’S ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT WE
HAVE THROUGHOUT THE RIO GRANDE
VALLEY.
IT HAS BEEN INCREASING TO.
WE CANNOT ATTRIBUTE TO
IMMIGRANTS AND WE ARE CONCERNED
AND WE WITH GOING TO DO WHATEVER
WE CAN.
GRIFF: JAVIER VILLALOBOS, THE
MAYOR OF MCALLEN, TEXAS THE
MAYOR CITY WHERE MORE THAN
700,000 MIGRANTS WITH COVID HAVE
BEEN RELEASED FROM BORDER
CONTROL SINCE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION BEGAN FLYING
CENTRAL AMERICAN AND MEXICAN
FAMILIES DEEP INTO MEXICO TO
DETER REPEAT CROSSINGS AS TIME
OF RISING COVID CONCERNS AND
SPOKESMAN NATIONAL BORDER PATROL
COUNCIL AND 3307 IN THE RIO
GRANDE VALLEY CHRIS CABRERA.
CHRIS, THANKS FOR TAKING TIME.
I KNOW THAT YOU’RE TIRED.
YOU GUYS ARE WORKING LONG HOURS,
BUT NOW THIS COVID THREAT MAYOR
VILLALOBOS SAYING THAT THE
THREAT TO YOU RIGHT THERE IN THE
RGV IN EXCESS OF 16% POSITIVITY
RATE, HOW BAD IS IT?
>> YOU KNOW, IT’S PRETTY BAD.
I KNOW WE HAVE AT LEAST 80 OF
OUR AGENTS, WELL, MORE THAN OF
80 AGENTS HAVE TESTED POSITIVE.
WE HAVE AT LEAST 150 IN
QUARANTINE.
AND IT’S -- THE NUMBERS ARE
GROWING EVERY DAY.
IT’S GETTING OUT OF CONTROL HERE
AND IT’S UNFORTUNATE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS JUST TURNING A
BLIND EYE TO WHAT’S GOING ON
DOWN HERE AND PUTTING OUR
COMMUNITIES AT -- AT RISK.
GRIFF: CHRIS, YOU’RE NOT ONLY AN
AGENT IN THE RGV BUT YOU’RE ALSO
A RESIDENT OF THE COMMUNITY OF
MCALLEN, HOW CONCERNING IS IT
NOW THAT YOU HAVE GOT A MAYOR
PLEADING FOR HELP AND FROTH
TIEING YOUR HANDS, SO TO SPEAK?
>> YOU KNOW, IT’S VERY
CONCERNING AND WE ARE THANKFUL
THAT MAYOR VILLALOBOS IS DOING
WHAT HE’S DOING.
IT’S UNFORTUNATE THE LAST MAYOR
OF MCALLEN JUST TURNED A BLIND
EYE TO IT AS WELL AS THE COUNTY
ADMINISTRATION.
THEY WERE CONSTANT I WILL SAYING
THERE’S NO CRISIS DOWN HERE,
THERE’S NO STATE OF EMERGENCY
AND ONLY WHEN THE NEWS BROKE THE
STORY OF COVID POSITIVE PEOPLE
THAT WERE RELEASED FROM CUSTODY,
ROAMING AROUND THE TOWNS AND
POTENTIALLY INFECTING OUR
CITIZENS, YOU KNOW, THAT’S WHEN
PEOPLE STARTED TO WAKE UP.
GRIFF: CHRIS, WHAT COULD THE
FROTH, WHAT WOULD THE
ADMINISTRATION DO RIGHT NOW TO
HELP ALLEVIATE THIS CRISIS?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, I THINK THEY
NEED TO COME DOWN HERE AND TAKE
A LOOK.
YOU KNOW, EVEN YOU’VE SEEN SOME
OF OUR MAKE-SHIFT INTAKE AREAS
RIGHT HERE IN THE MCALLEN AREA,
LALA JOYA AREA, IT’S JUST A
MAKE-SHIFT BALL FIELD WHERE WE
HAVE 400, 500 PEOPLE AT A TIME
WAITING OUTSIDE FOR -- FOR A BUS
TO COME.
AND THERE’S VERY LITTLE
PROTECTION FOR THE ELEMENTS,
THERE’S NO RESTROOM FACILITIES.
PEOPLE ARE JUST USING THE
RESTROOM IN FULL VIEW OF THE
PUBLIC ON THE SIDE OF THE ROAD
AND THAT’S DISGUSTING NOT TO
MENTION VERY DANGEROUS AS FAR AS
SOME OF THE ILLNESS THAT IS CAN
COME FROM THAT AND, YOU KNOW,
THEY HAVE MONEY FOR THE YARDS,
MONEY PER PEOPLE TO STAY HOME
AND NOT WORK AND WE CAN GET PORT
A POTTIES DOWN HERE.
REAL PEOPLE ARE PAYING THE PRICE
DOWN HERE.
WE ARE HAVING HEAT CASUALTIES
EVERY DAY FROM SITTING OUT IN
THE HOT SUN AND THE HUMID
WEATHER WE HAVE DOWN HERE.
GRIFF: CHRIS, THE CRISIS ISN’T
JUST IN RGV, 1,000 MILES AWAY
FOX NEWS JUST GETTING THIS VIDEO
IN FROM EARLY THIS MORNING AT
THE OCEAN BEACH PIER IN -- NEAR
SAN DIEGO, CALIFORNIA, YOU SEE
PETER SHOT THIS VIDEO, ONE OF MY
CLOSEST SURFING FRIENDS, WENT
OUT TO GO TO SURF AND THE BORDER
PATROL WAS THERE AND THEY LOOKED
BACK ON THE SURF LINE CAMERA AND
SAW AT 2:45 LOCAL CALIFORNIA
TIME, 11 INDIVIDUALS JUMPED OUT
OF THIS, SCATTERED LEFT THE BOAT
BEHIND.
THOSE ARE GOT AWAYS.
HOW MUCH OF A THREAT IS THE OPEN
BORDER RIGHT NOW IN TERMS OF
NATIONAL SECURITY IN THE -- IN
THE UNKNOWN FOLKS THAT ARE
CROSSING WITHOUT GETTING
APPREHENDED?
>> YOU KNOW, THE NUMBERS FOR GOT
AWAYS ARE ASTRONOMICAL.
I KNOW THE ADMINISTRATION PATROL
PUTS OUT A CERTAIN AMOUNT THAT
THEY’RE, YOU KNOW, 40%, 20%, BUT
WE ARE CLOSER TO MAYBE A 50% GOT
AWAY RATE HERE NATIONWIDE.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF PEOPLE THAT
ARE TRYING TO GET AWAY DO GET
AWAY BECAUSE WE DON’T HAVE THE
MANPOWER TO COVER.
WE HAVE VERY FEW PEOPLE OUT IN
THE FIELD BECAUSE WE ARE ALL
BABYSITTING OR SICK.
GRIFF: JUST AS A TESTAMENT TO
THE TOLL, THE HOW MANY TOLL, WE
HAVE VIDEO, YOU WERE ASSISTING A
TODDLER, A TENDER-AGE MIGRANT
OUT IN THE FIELD.
WE CAN SEE THERE THIS YOUNG
GIRL, HOW BAD IS IT?
HOW MUCH OF A HUMAN TOLL IS IT
TAKING?
>> YOU KNOW, WE LUCKILY THE
BORDER PATROL -- WE HAVE OUR OWN
EMT TO RESPOND UNTIL EMS CAN GET
THERE BUT OUR MEDICS ARE RUNNING
BACK AND FORTH EVERY DAY ALL DAY
WHENEVER WE ARE ON DUTY, 3, 4,
5, 7, 10 CALLS ON A SHIFT.
THAT LITTLE GIRL, SHE WAS
UNCONSCIOUS WHEN WE FOUND HER
WHEN THEY BROUGHT HER UP AND THE
AGENT ON THE SCENE DID A GOOD
JOB OF COOLING HER DOWN BUT WE
ARE SEEING THAT DAILY AND IT’S
HEARTBREAKING TO SEE ANYBODY IN
THAT CONDITION BUT EVEN MORE SO
A 3-YEAR-OLD.
GIVE GRIFF IT IS, INDEED, CHRIS